welcome to plate to date today I have  three gentlemen making glances for me I  cannot wait I'm David I'm Ian I'm Andrew  what I'm looking for in a man being  open-minded is a big one somebody that's  open to trying weird things so I want  some that matches my goofiness my  athleticism and also like intelligence  so today I'll be serving a vegan beef  barreco and the inside will have  mushrooms onions the vegan beef crumble  I have the vegan just egg as you know  the egg wash with sesame seeds boom an  oven here we go for only eight minutes  ain't that a treat most people say Bon  Appetit but in Hebrew but they have on  oh yeah okay that alone I feel like  should win this this effort tells me  that in a relationship he will pay  attention to detail he pays attention to  the little things and showing that he's  willing to put in the extra effort for  his partner I mean I guess it's above  and beyond tomato but to me like that  was pretty simple  [Laughter]